[Música]
tu parsimonial
Álvaro Muchas gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros en 24 Muchas
gracias a vosotros
estrenaste tu primer álbum la cantera
del año pasado después de varios
sencillos que tuvieron un gran éxito
Cómo fue este trabajo para unir las
canciones bajo una lógica común y dentro
de una misma propuesta
Pues para mí
empecé a trabajar en el álbum como en
hace tres años y realmente como que
cuando empecé a componer canciones como
que no tenía todavía como este hilo
conductor que podéis unirla el álbum eso
que creo que fue como con el con el
tiempo de ir agrupando las canciones y
ver el sentido que iba cobrando por sí
mismo y fue cuando pues surgió el título
como de la cantera no
para mí eso estaba muy vinculado con con
lo que era pues la música que había
aprendido Pues en el pueblo de mi abuela
que es donde empecé a cantar y a tomar
la guitarra y como todas estas
influencias que que conocí allí no Y la
música que empecé a escuchar allí y
realmente el término de Cantera hacía
referencia a cómo nos llamaban como de
Pequeños a los niños no como pues esta
es la cantera como la como un relevo
generacional de alguna manera no y para
mí esto como también significaba sobre
todo en pues en mi caso concreto en
poner una abuela que es un pueblo en el
interior de Aragón que que sí que como
muchos otros sitios ha sufrido como este
abandono rural no como las ciudades como
que
Así que como veo el
o esta ilusión Pues de como las futuras
generaciones que van a como a permitir
como que estos cuerpos como que sigan
teniendo vida no Y que sigan perdurando
la gente te conoce sobre todo por tu
tema Guantanamera que salió en 2018 unos
años después hacen tenido que hizo que
esa canción en particular funcionará
tanto con el público y cuál es ahora tu
relación con esa canción
pues
finalmente como que es
fue como la segunda canción o la primera
canción que compartí en en
las plataformas O sea la grabé en casa
como sin ningún como sin esperar nada a
cambio y fue como cuando se viralizado
de alguna manera no y al final es la que
me ha acompañado a todos sitios y la que
ha servido como como de estandarte como
de mi música no y yo creo que como igual
que mucha gente como que odia como esa
canción que tiene que cantar siempre
como por obligación a mí luego las
canciones o como con mis canciones como
voy viviendo pues como diferentes
relaciones a lo largo del tiempo no
comunes pero creo que en esta en
concreto
al al significar tantas cosas es una
canción que nunca voy a dejar de como de
sentir al cantarlo
y a pesar de que el reconocimiento y la
fama llegaron gracias a internet a las
redes sociales tú tocas una música folk
con referencias tradicionales Cómo vives
este contraste
Pues realmente creo que es que no es tan
raro porque
creo que en mi caso al haber creo que he
crecido Pues en una generación que que
nos hemos como nutrido Pues de mucha
referencias no o el haber tenido puesto
este acceso a internet o como toda la
vorágine como de información
pues como que no hiciera una cosa con la
otra el tener Pues en tu Playlist o en
tus gustos musicales Pues el reggaetón o
poder tener el acceso a una canción
tradicional de hace 80 años Y quizá
alguien desde 20 años no podría tener
ese acceso no no podría como descubrir o
indagar como más sobre la música de del
pasado y creo que esto es como muy un
reflejo de
la juventud o del gusto musical de la
juventud que creo que ha estado mucho
más abierto y no hay Como tanta
Quizá antes a la gente pues le gustaba
el rock y a gente que no tenía acceso
escuchar música y escuchar lo que sonaba
en la radio y estaba con mucho todo
mucho más dividido y creo que ahora se
muestra como que tenemos un abanico muy
amplio de gustos
y es este mismo amor hacia el folclor
que lo que te hizo conectar tanto con
América Latina
en una entrevista yo leí que dijiste que
hablar del folklore latinoamericano Es
como hablar del océano porque es inmenso
y hay diferentes colores Qué bonito
Pues la verdad que sí o sea porque estas
referencias en las que en las que empecé
como a conocer cuando empezaba a tocar
las primeras canciones que tocaba
eran del folklore latinoamericano mera
es una referencia una canción mítica de
la canción cubana y sigue siempre como
que he sentido un vínculo muy muy fuerte
con todo el imaginario y todo todas las
historias de la música latinoamericana y
sobre todo como pues referentes como
Pues Chavela Vargas o caetano veloso o
Simón Díaz que son como que se agrupan
todo en un continente pero es que son
mundos completamente diferentes y
siempre he sentido este vínculo y el
llegar como por primera vez aquí sabes
Sientes como que de alguna manera como
que hayas estado pero como que tienes
como todo por descubrir
y bueno Haces muchas referencias a este
continente en tu música con tanamera el
mezcal pero es un continente donde nunca
viviste ves como una posibilidad en el
futuro pasar más tiempo Acá
conocer artistas viajar y componer
La verdad que sí porque la primera vez
que que estuve en septiembre fue la
primera vez que visité latinoamérica
estuve en México por primera vez claro
descubrí como descubrir como un mundo
nuevo no el o ver como una escena en la
ciudad como completamente diferente a la
que puede ocurrir en cualquier ciudad de
españa no de pues músicos que se juntan
géneros que es que se tocan y la verdad
que es que siempre o al menos en este
viaje Pues siempre como que me vuelvo
como lleno como de inspiración no y de y
de referencias Así que tengo muchas
ganas de poder volver pero con tiempo o
sea no el tocar y irme y me apetece
mucho ir viajar a Venezuela
venezolano y aquí en Colombia pues
descubrimos como todos los dos lados del
océano no como y descubrí como todos los
tipos de música Y como tan tan
originales de cada sitio y al final Creo
que nunca creo que no te morirás
aprendiendo como todo lo que lo que hay
por descubrir además Aquí tienes un
público bastante firme por ejemplo en
Bogotá abrieron una segunda fecha de
concierto cuando se dieron cuenta que la
primera se llenó súper rápidamente y la
gente sabe perfectamente tus letras como
te sentiste frente a eso
es muy bonito o sea
el claro cuando cuando sales de tu
tierra y te vas como un sitio tan lejano
y que la gente como que ya ha conectado
antes de conocerte con tu música y con
lo que estás contando es
una sensación muy fuerte y el el la otra
noche aquí y en Bogotá Fue increíble
como ver la gente como con tanta energía
y tan entregada y
sabiendo que todas las canciones desde
que empezar concierto hasta la última
que fue Fue increíble
trabajas siempre o casi siempre con el
mismo director para tus videoclips Pedro
artola cuéntanos Cómo nació este Dúo
artístico pues nació de una manera la
más
inocente posible
nosotros y lo conocí por redes y sería
como su trabajo pero como por la
estética que tenía como en sus fotos ni
siquiera había hecho ni siquiera que
había hecho vídeos y le propuse entonces
hacer el vídeo de guantánamera si
viniese a mi pueblo para para grabarlo y
desde entonces ahí se forjó una un
vínculo muy fuerte que más allá de los
vídeos pues Pedro ha sido Alguien que ha
estado muy presente en la dirección
creativa y que ayuda como a generar como
todo el imaginario de los vídeos de y de
las historias que acompañan a la música
que al final Como me parece la manera
más
Como creo que es la manera como de
enriquecer las historias que estás
contando Noel el aportar Pues todo ese
ese
ha sido como detrás de la música y tú te
implicas mucho en la parte creativa de
estos vídeos
la verdad que
siempre como que desde el principio
cuando no hacía vídeos
siempre he estado como interesado pues
como en todo lo artístico no en lo
creativo y recuerdo que al principio
Pues mis carteles para los conciertos
me los diseñaba yo
y siempre creo que al final si tú estás
como contando una historia con tus
canciones creo que el supervisar o el
tener atado como lo que acompaña tu
música es lo que tienes que hacer porque
si vas otra persona
no tiene sentido no al final tienes que
contar tú lo que lo que lo que lo que
quieres contar y lo que y lo que está
vinculado a tu música y hablando de tu
conexión con la parte visual del arte te
quería Mostrar un vídeo de un gran
coreógrafo francés que se llama kush que
hizo un baile con tu canción agua y
mezcal
[Música]
Con la frente platea me levanto y no me
quito
[Música]
que el tiempo sin ver nadie
el alma con agua y mezcal
[Música]
visto en El vendaval
bailando
[Música]
España cómo te sientes al saber que
ahora
tu trabajo inspira a otros artistas a
crear
pues es la verdad que sí que es
increíble no O sea el sobre todo como
cuando cuando implica como otras
disciplinas no que no es que no solo con
la música sino cuando pues alguien pues
hace un cuadro o de un videoclip o
cuando alguien pues hace una coreografía
una canción
o sea también pasar incluso con
escritores de nombres que dicen Pues
este capítulo pues me inspirado en esta
canción o sea creo que es como el como
la mecánica del arte no O sea que al
final nunca deja ver como una
inspiración o como que nada nace de la
nada no O sea siempre hay como una
referencia que alimenta como la
siguiente bueno Álvaro Muchas gracias
Muchísimas gracias a ti
[Música]